みなさんこんにちは
今日の料理の時間がやってまいりました
それでは講師を紹介いたします
ピラニアダケ・ハ・生de食エネエノ助先生です
やふへゐ:こんにちは
やふへゐ:先生今日は何を作っていただけるのでしょうか
やふへゐ:先生？
やふへゐ:肉じゃが　ありがとうございます
やふへゐ:では今日はですね
やふへゐ:まぁ男子特に大好きなんじゃないでしょうか肉じゃが
やふへゐ:ピラニアダケ・ハ・生de食エネエノ助先生の肉じゃが講座ということで
やふへゐ:では早速
やふへゐ:それでは食エネエノ助先生
やふへゐ:肉じゃがを今日は作っていただけるということで
はじめ:はい
はじめ:はいというわけで今回肉じゃがを作っていくわけなんですけども
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:というものをご存知でしょうか
やふへゐ:いえ
はじめ:こちらにこういうのがあります
はじめ:インド人のアドバイスを完全無視して作ったカレーがありまして
はじめ:裏にはもう完全…そのアドバイスをせっかくしたのに
はじめ:無視された方の画像も載っております
やふへゐ:なるほど
はじめ:ガン無視数もマックスになっていますね〜
はじめ:でわたくしこれ食べたことがあるんですけど
はじめ:これすごいのがほんとに美味しんですよ
やふへゐ:へ〜〜〜
はじめ:マジで美味しい
はじめ:これ逆に僕は、逆の発想で
はじめ:例えば肉じゃがといえば
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:おふくろの味っていうイメージありません？
やふへゐ:はいありますね
はじめ:ありますよね
はじめ:逆におふくろに僕、肉じゃがのアドバイスめっちゃもらったんですよ
はじめ:事前におふくろから肉じゃがのアドバイスめっちゃもらったんで
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:おふくろからのアドバイスを完全に無視して
はじめ:もう逆のことするくらいの
やふへゐ:なるほどですね
はじめ:完全に無視して肉じゃがを作れば
はじめ:すごい美味しい
はじめ:が作れるんじゃないかなと僕思いまして
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:ちょっと作ってみようかと思っております
やふへゐ:なるほどですね
やふへゐ:では早速先生お願いします
はじめ:はい
やふへゐ:では先生えー準備が整ったようですので
やふへゐ:早速肉じゃがを作っていただければと思います
やふへゐ:お願いいたします
はじめ:わかりました
はじめ:作っていきましょう
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:お醤油、みりん、砂糖
はじめ:まぁここら辺がベースとしてあるんですけども
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:まぁ母親のアドバイスによっては使わないものも出てきますので
はじめこっからはちょっと臨機応変に作っていきましょう
やふへゐ:なるほど　はい
はじめ:というわけで実質
はじめ:といった感じですね
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:まずじゃがいもを切りましょう
はじめ:これですね
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:じゃがいもを使っていきましょう
はじめ:まずは洗っていきます
はじめ:はい、いいんじゃないでしょうか
はじめ:じゃがいも剥いていきましょう
やふへゐ:はい
やふへゐ:えへへｗ
はじめ:え、ピーラーないとどうなるんですか
やふへゐ:このまま使うしかないんじゃ　それか包丁で
やふへゐ:あれ包丁もない
はじめ:あ、包丁はあるんですよ
やふへゐ:よかったよかった
はじめ:実はですね母からのアドバイスで
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:すごいのがきてるんですよ
やふへゐ:はいはい
やふへゐ:おお！
はじめ:ほぼ実質新じゃがですね
やふへゐ:調べた結果ですねやっぱ
はじめ:芽がなければいいんでしょ？
やふへゐ:芽がなければ逆に皮自体にはなんか栄養素があるらしいです
はじめ:はいというわけで次に
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:人参を切っていくんですけど
はじめ:さすがにピーラーがないとちょっと難しいので
やふへゐ:確かに
はじめ:まずピーラーを買いに行きましょう
やふへゐ:ははｗｗ
やふへゐ:料理番組でピーラーを買いに行くってすごい
はじめ:あはは
やふへゐ:んんん
やふへゐ:あああ　よし
はじめ:では早速人参を剥いていきましょう
やふへゐ:はい
やふへゐ:あー素晴らしい素晴らしい
はじめ:では続いて玉ねぎ切っていきましょう
やふへゐ:お願いします
はじめ:というわけで
はじめ:あ、全然まだでした
はじめ:全然まだだったｗ
はじめ:じゃあこれをこれから切っていきます
やふへゐ:はい、お願いします
はじめ:どうなんかペラペラペラペラ
やふへゐ:あ、ペラペラペラペラ
やふへゐ:先生
はじめ:あーマジやっべこれ
やふへゐ:あ、すごっやばいｗやばい
はじめ:あー待ってなーいや全然大丈夫じゃないんですけど
はじめ:はいいかがでしょうか、こんな感じでーす
はじめ:次はしらたきを準備しましょう
やふへゐ:しらたきですね
はじめ:あのここから母からのアドバイスがあります
やふへゐ:きました
はじめ:おふくろワンポイントアドバイス
はじめ:あのしらたきは結んであるやつを使いなさいと
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:これちゃんと結んであるやつなんですけども
はじめ:理由を聞くと
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:あのその糸コンがバラバラになるのがちょっと嫌だみたいな
やふへゐ:あ〜
はじめ:こと言ってたんで
やふへゐ:なるほどですね
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:ママが言うこと破るって
はじめ:ははは　いいねぇー
はじめ:ははは　あ”ぁ”〜〜
はじめ:ぅぁ”〜〜
はじめ:ほどいてやったぜ〜
はじめ:次は鍋にサラダ油を入れていきましょう
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:じゃ油を入れていきます
はじめ:小さじ2杯です
はじめ:やべっオーバーしたやべ
はじめ:オーバーしたほんとに
はじめ:で、熱していきます
はじめ:待って　おぃなんでなんでなんでなんで
やふへゐ:なになになになに
はじめ:水ちょっと入ってた
やふへゐ:うわーー
はじめ:待って助けてー
はじめ:誰かーーーー
やふへゐ:ああああ
はじめ:よしっおっけーっす落ち着きましたね
はじめ:なんでなんで焦げてる
はじめ:やり直します
やふへゐ:くっさ　うわくっさ
はじめ:うわぁ　あああああああああ
やふへゐ:ああああああああ
はじめ:えー油を間違えていました　失礼いたしました
はじめ:ちゃんとした油でやっていきましょう
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:ではまず玉ねぎを炒めていきましょう
はじめ:うわーマジで美味そうだなぁ
はじめ:はい、というわけで今玉ねぎを炒めているわけなんですけども
はじめ:ここで母からのワンポイントアドバイス
はじめ:ここで本来なら肉を一緒に入れて炒めます
はじめ:ですが私の母からのアドバイス
はじめ:肉ではなくベーコンを使えと言うアドバイスをいただいております
はじめ:これがなんかうちの肉じゃがの特徴で
はじめ:肉使わないんですよ
はじめ:ヒラヒラの薄切りかブロックの小さいベーコンで
はじめ:肉じゃがを作ると言っているので
はじめ:ベーコンも無理だし肉も無理だと
はじめ:こちらの今回チーズかまぼこを使っていこうと思います
はじめ:一応わたくし魚なら食べれますので
はじめ:ベーコンでもなく肉でもなく
はじめ:チーズかまぼこを使って肉じゃがを作っていこうと思います
はじめ:あ、やべ
はじめ:ここでまたもやワンポイントアドバイスでございます
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:じゃがいも人参は
はじめ:切ってから長めにレンジでチンしてから使うらしいです
はじめ:これは時間短縮と煮崩れ防止のためらしいです
やふへゐ:へ〜〜〜〜
はじめ:やんねぇーけどなーーー　はっははー
はじめ:というわけでこのまま入れていきましょうはい
やふへゐ:直で　はい
はじめ:では全部入れていきまあああ
やふへゐ:あああああああああああ
はじめ:やばいやばい
はじめ:じゃあ全部入れていきまーす
はじめ:で、炒めていきまーす
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:で、ここで母からのワンポイントアドバイス
はじめ:えーっと玉ねぎ炒めてじゃがいも人参を炒めたときに
はじめ:砂糖を入れるらしいですこのタイミングで
はじめ:ここで入れることによって焦がさないようになるらしいです
やふへゐ:はぁ〜〜〜
はじめ:入れないけどねぇー
はじめ:というわけで砂糖と真逆の存在塩を準備しました
やふへゐ:え、ちょっと待ってｗ
はじめ:このタイミングで塩を投入していきましょう
やふへゐ:うっそー
はじめ:あ、まぁあぁまぁ
やふへゐ:まぁまぁまぁ
はじめ:はい、ではそろそろ水を投入していきます
はじめ；じゃあ入れます
やふへゐ:うわぁすごい、やべやべ怖っ
はじめ；あ、でもいいんじゃないですか？どうどうどう、どうですか？
やふへゐ:あ、素晴らしいと思います
はじめ:え、ほんとに肉じゃがだやばい、生まれて初めて作った
はじめ:チーズかまぼこを入れていきマソ湯
はじめ:オッケィ
はじめ:このうちにみりんを入れていきます
はじめ:こんなもん？もうちょい？
やふへゐ:そうだね
はじめ:ここでおふくろから衝撃の技です
はじめ:えーっと水を入れて煮てるときに
はじめ:お醤油を入れるらしいです
やふへゐ:なるほどですね
はじめ:多分風味が出てくるんでしょうね
やふへゐ:うん
やふへゐ:味付けです
はじめ:入れねぇーけどなー
はじめ:醤油の逆といえばこちら
はじめ:代わりにカゴメソなんて顔してんすかｗｗ
はじめ:でもいい味付けになると思うんすよねー
やふへゐ:うわうわうわうわ
はじめ:はは、うぇーい
やふへゐ:はは
はじめ:ええーい
はじめ:ついでにポッカレモンも入れてみましょうか
やふへゐ:ちょっと待って
はじめ:レモン感大事な気がするんですよね
はじめ:ポッカ入れていきまーす
はじめ:これで一応おふくろからのアドバイスは全て全無視しました
やふへゐ:はい
やふへゐ:えー先生
やふへゐ:肉…あー肉じゃがが完成いたしました
はじめ:なんで今詰まったの？
はじめ:肉、、じゃがではないかもしれません
はじめ:母のアドバイスを無視し続けたことにより
はじめ:肉の概念が失ってしまい
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:チズかまぼこを入れてしまった
はじめ:つまり、チーズかまぼこじゃがになってしまいました
やふへゐ:あのー作ってた時から思ってたんすけど匂いはすごいいいんです
はじめ:うん
やふへゐ:早速いただきましょうか　はい
はじめ:いただきましょう
はじめ:普通に味が気になるところではある
やふへゐ:スープからいっていいですか？じゃあ
はじめ:そうだなスープからいこう
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:いただきます
やふへゐ:はいいただきます
はじめ:で、大丈夫だまだわからんまだわからん
はじめ:あのスープは所詮は飾りにすぎんから　この肉じゃがは
やふへゐ:あーぁちょ確かに
やふへゐ:じゃーちょっと
はじめ:ほんとは味、味が一番大事だから
やふへゐ:わかりました
はじめ:味を食わないとわからない部分が多々あるので
はじめ:味を重点的に感じていただきたいとこではある
やふへゐ:ははｗ
はじめ:どうですか、味の方は？
やふへゐ:あの
はじめ:えっえっうそだー　マジー？
やふへゐ:俺結構これ好きですね
はじめ:マジすかー？
やふへゐ:あのー結構しっとりしててあっさりしててうまいんすよ
はじめ:私も食べてみる　私も、私も食べてみる
やふへゐ:僕はですよ
やふへゐ:どうすか？
はじめ:うん
やふへゐ:でしょー
はじめ:なんかソースが合ってますね
やふへゐ:そうなんですよ
はじめ:なんやかんや
はじめ:はい、ただ…一ついいですか？
やふへゐ:はい
はじめ:マジで合ってないです　食いました？かまぼこ
やふへゐ:まだです
はじめ:食ってみてください多分びっくりしますよ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】